we're trying this again we're going live
I am going to fill the questions
[Music]
[Music]
now
so then we driving functionalities with
the car basically driving so similar to
water supply and so right now and this
is right now they only / but we are very
opened like more and more devices
actually could support the support of a
button which is one main reason why we
pilot open source so that people can
actually port it
you have any plans to use that or did
you actually use any simulation when you
do that within the system or is it all
on my face when I know we do we do is
already simulator so we do use
simulators to plan regression test to
develop our features it was like we have
to use simulators so my cartoon again
we've stands we use simulators but the
interesting simulators that we're
building is the simulator that we hope
is gonna allow us applying personal
learning to driving this is kind of a
different simulator that requires us
having like a very good understanding of
the surrounding and then creating a
system where the car can be
automatically rewarded if he drives well
and being like the safe honest when it
doesn't drive well I'm to matically
understanding how to drive this is like
one of the George Cross be that you are
working on which allows us to have like
other bodies more scaling and having
more leverage of the data that we have
without having to our code teachers for
planning so it's some sort of like how
do we help me apply machine learning to
the block if it does like the planning
of the Sodra here and so this is what
simulated everything
can you select the particle of
communication in cars like a different
like its use the way that these issues
communicate with each other is true and
user can call to publish if they are
coming up communication on a network
I mean my pen itself is off the network
like you can't like any car as I can
it's can portable communication seems
like many years is actually mandatory to
use to your scanner since I think the
eight is so now I mean you have to have
physical access to the car in order to
have like any sort of like issues like
the Reagan issues is like the fact that
we have devices that are connected on
internet and yes you have to be you have
to make sure that you cannot ever you
are going to have a tax through the
internet connectivity of your device yes
our device is interconnected and that's
how we yeah you know the same thing
basically that like the same processor
is but like many many many many cars
like software software like on the same
problem as before we're gonna see more
and more cars having capability of being
like updated over yeah right this is the
kind of thing that we believe it's
absolutely necessary it's kind of like
we believe is like super strange they're
like $30,000 object that you buy today
cannot be updated on yeah like if you
need a software update and I guarantee
like safety yes I mean of course is our
concern right but like how many cars
have been act in the last like how many
cars like you or they have been hacked
and they made some damage because they
be not
I had about about one so it is a concern
clarify what she said earlier about
reading the censors so if there whatever
sensor suite is in place or a task that
constants are you're able to use those
sensors and incorporated into quick and
then towards the answer you were saying
about ions that are available for
purchase you mentioned something about
if you wanted to know more about
positioning of your vehicle what how
precise is so do you some lousy oh so
it's like so this is like you blocks I'm
not sure if you are familiar with this
use like a new blocks processing antenna
wherever you have access actually to all
GPS and so it's all about like how much
post processing you do about it and you
can get like very precise that you can
actually like to use the correct like
post processing and so in this regard
okay this is like a little spoiler but
this week we're gonna release a lot here
so this week we're gonna like there's an
engineer like our health organization
who is actually going to going to make
an open-source studies of post processor
or GPS data and get like the best of
course--it is you can get the fighting
force processing I mean like it's not
micro GPS as opposed to regular
thank you question yeah well so we do
the post-processing not assuming that
you do like any vision feature magic
which allows you to be even way more
precise so just by GPS a-gps processing
and some sort of light filter like
playing a Kalman filter and you're like
sense so there is like accelerometer you
can get between like help meet their
procedure well you would be able to
localize but if you have the map then
you cannot centimeter across because
once you know which lane you are into
then you just have to find like some
visual feature like little eyes and
localize yourself within very accurately
which is centimeter within the lane
lines so yes I mean this is not assuming
any visual organization if you want to
use visualization that you can get like
centimeter accurate because for example
I necessarily you know which lane which
lane you are into you see where the lane
lane lines are and then you just
localized yourself relatively to the
main lines for which you perfectly know
the position because they are on your
high-definition maps and then you can
organize yourself at least in one
dimension which is dimension that
matters within like a few centimeter how
much is it obviously like five
centimeter I mean truly like all the
crises
precisely processing but I'm funny then
I'll commute the week post processing
desk we're gonna use the tools do I
should achieve that and this is all the
software that goes yes
oops sorry we have our Canadian crew
that's downstairs so maybe I'll have
better film you guys while I go get that
Canadian so sorry to interrupt
yeah he's talking just there's 24 people
okay can you do me a great big favor can
you hold them until I'm back I'm just
gonna run to get the Canadians
so we
you know
[Music]
you know
I think
new generations around tenant care
applause yeah Ilan thought that might be
enough but if it's not they're gonna
replace the hardware because that's
still kind of industry yes
whether it's to not just self-driving
with some of our applications when the
machine learns and it creates a solution
to neural net so to speak you don't even
understand anymore exactly how it works
all right so there's this ghosting of
machines so once you are
[Music]
I started like mechanical engineering
and I was busy dealing at bachelor and
then I switch to automatic mechanical
engineers for master I moved to United
States I need some work in bacon so I
moved Tesla worked at NASA for about
like five six years pilot and I met
George if you stay with the founder
combi and I got very excited about the
project and I'm Steve so I'm very
excited about like the idea of like
solving practical problems like SCU job
I can get excited about problems where I
seen a huge opportunity of like making
things better and I just see like a huge
proportion of my investment that are
sources like overnight level four I just
feel like okay well let's go to like let
me treat Stephanie like available and so
I'm excited about solving problems that
I've like positive actually impact on
people's life
the understanding is issues of
proprietor eNOS about people's hard work
so currently and replace anybody OS and
most us jurisdictions in most the world
you invalidate your warranty do you have
plans to so could obviously challenge
well yeah of course I said before like
our our plan is to work with you is to
work with humans player we have to work
together like in order to make uh people
successful we need to ship it like we
need to work together to yet and so yeah
this is the plan like the plan is like
it's not anybody dating like the world
come with aftermarket product it's
actually working working with them and
working together like exchanging
information about like how they are the
interface of the cab works and making it
compatible compatible we're working at
the point like they do with the polar
project they're trying to do the same
thing I think like their approach is the
totally different from us
we try to make it working on tasks that
people own which is why like we want to
make it accessible right we want to make
like open pilots something that people
can access and so we to like definitely
try to achieve our end goal but the way
that we're doing is very different like
we try to make it open pilots working on
to the ACE car they're trying to make up
a fight like they are polar projects
working on we we cast that cost more
than $1,000 and just research projects
and so they're like and it only works on
like very heavy computers like we use by
consumer other we use things that you
can find in folks liking the smartphones
you can buy today is the alga that is
sufficient to run open Python so the
direction is very different we try to
value like accessibility
and only like transparency and only
adoptability half of the features while
while I think Apple is taking more like
let's define like something that means
like very heavy they basically didn't
consider like any constraints in term of
like a car's accessibility and so the
part to get there is different we have 7
million mice we plant worth like 50 live
in a year they said like more than 100
ma and 100 million mice I don't think
like the polar project is ever gonna get
close to that like Apple is now gonna be
able to define the whole HD Maps wanted
from the day today their devices collect
because the amount of people using their
devices is poisoning exists it's
possible it's possible but like I mean
okay so which which which hardware do
they need that do they need like they
need like lidar so do they need which I
mean like I have not seen like car
driving with the poor law and having
like satisfactory level to systems so
like I've seen like they most of the
expensive cars with gliders coming
Estrada short on the car probably
driving with the polar but like it
doesn't seem like they are on a path of
cheap ability in terms of like are they
on a part of like shipping their product
anything so are they ready to ship if
anytime soon so we try to behave in that
sense by developing it on cars and she
are aware that can be found today's
like automobile Sgt if it's five years
for to build into a car etc and you're
talking about level two and hopefully
level four will have taken off in Queens
at least in some parts of the world then
what is this selling point so if I'm
it's your line art I'm an OEM what are
you going to tell me that is going to
make me say yes to yeah so before as I
said that it's not about it's not gonna
make like Martin the majority of
people's life better it's only gonna
work like in very limited environment
it's not proven to work yet I know like
way manaus that they ship this month
like they are their first like project
program I mean there's a like a tire
behind behind the wheel it only works
with very climate where they're like in
Arizona I'm not like I don't think like
a level four he's gonna he's gonna enter
ownership this is like the main point
like people are still gonna buy cars for
man many it's like decades from now
so the problem like we're not competing
wait wait wait we're not competing with
with this idea of like creating level
four system I actually oh but the basic
seed I'm not so sure they gonna make
people's life better because like
probably San Francisco is like traffic
is traffic is the main proper right and
so making transportation cheaper in cars
does it make traffic better now for is
gonna make it worse like it's probably
gonna make like way more working
surfaces people I mean it's probably
gonna make like our can get bored it's
coming the public cheaper plug Wars like
we're gonna spend more time job so
I am saying the comma doesn't try to
make a community in cities cheaper it's
gonna try to make it better but not
cheap he's gonna try to make it just
being like trying to solve like that
could be solved in different ways maybe
better public transportation maybe like
we already have what we need not so sure
it's gonna solve practical problems but
I'm excited about the project I'm
excited about the technical challenge it
seems like a cool body project let's
stop there so people can get some food
and engineers are here we have a we have
a shop we have a mobile shop with us so
if you want to get tour t-shirts if you
want to get Aeons if you want to get
your a Spanos whatever Nick we'll be
working that back there or wherever Nick
outside
yeah help your guys to pizza and thank
you so much for coming like I said
people will be here to continue
answering your questions and yeah thank
you guys
all right five Scoobies